قال زعيم سابق
أه في بولندا ذات مرة أن الخطوة
الأولى للروس هي جورجيا
الخطوة الثانية هي أوكرانيا الخطوة الثالثة هي
بولندا ، هل تشعر أنت وبولندا بتهديد حقيقي
من روسيا
لذلك لا شك على الإطلاق أه
المجتمع البولندي يخاف من روسيا
لدينا  حصلت على بعض التجارب التاريخية
أحيانًا يُطلب
مني أن أقدم لهم وصفًا موجزًا ​​للتاريخ البولندي
قل الحقيقة إذا نظرت إلى
تاريخ النشر الفترة الأخيرة
التي رأيناها هي
قليلة جدًا ومتباعدة عندما
استمتعنا بالسلام في بولندا أه  عشرات
السنين من السلام ،
لكن تاريخنا يمتد لأكثر من
1000 عام من التاريخ مع ألمانيا و
400 عام من
الحرب مع روسيا ، كما كان لدينا أيضًا
أقسام في بولندا ، لم تكن
موجودة على الخريطة لمدة 123 عامًا.
روسيا الإرهابية ثم تم غزونا من
قبل السوفييت في عام 1920 ، ثم غزتنا روسيا مرة أخرى
مع ألمانيا أخرى في
سبتمبر 1939
وكانت هذه بداية
الحرب العالمية الثانية بالضبط.
قُتلوا في عام 1940 في
قطع حيث قتل الروس
بالرصاص في مؤخرة رؤوسهم
12000 ضابط بولندي أخذوهم
كأسرى حرب في انتهاك لجميع
الأعراف هذا هو تاريخنا وبعد ذلك
بقينا في دائرة النفوذ الروسي
وكنا وراء  ستارة حديدية ،
لذا فهي تاريخ مأساوي
يعرفها جميع
الأشخاص البولنديين جيدًا ويخشى الأشخاص الملمعون من أنهم لا
يريدون أن يجدوا أنفسهم في مجال النفوذ الروسي